monsieur le président mesdames les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je voulais tout
d'abord vous dire combien nous sommes
reconnaissants de cette audition qui
vient certes assez tôt dans le processus
on vient de l'évoquer à l'instant mais
qui j'en suis sûre ce nous aidera à être
constructif dans la fabrication de cette
loi vous avez reçu donc le document
projets de lois confortant le respect
des principes de la république le
protestantisme alerte et conteste c'est
le plaidoyer de la fédération
protestante et je pense que vous avez
aussi reçu les réponses aux questions
écrites que vous nous avez fait parvenir
il ya hier donc que voilà vous avez vous
avez avec la plume de monsieur roch les
réponses sur lesquels d'ailleurs nous
pourrons revenir tout à l'heure
j'aimerais en propos liminaire est assez
bref introduire notre notre position et
puis je laisserai la parole à monsieur
roch sur les propositions l'épreuve les
quatre propositions qui sont les nôtres
et et d'autre le cas échéant est ce que
je voudrais dire au fond tient en quatre
mots
le premier celui qui d'ailleurs titre
notre document alerte le deuxième mot
est celui d'intelligence ou
d'intelligence collective le troisième
mot est donc le mot de propositions
c'est les fameuses propositions que nous
faisons est le dernier mot qui plaît
j'allais dire ici dans ce lieu comme
dans les églises c'est le mot de
promesses mais en l'occurrence il s'agit
de la promesse républicaine
voilà l'alertent du protestantisme et
son plaidoyer ne sont pas une posture
il y a aujourd'hui un projet de loi qui
que
pour la première fois depuis 1905
accumule une série de contraintes et
d'obligations et oublie je l'espère non
pas délibérément mais par inadvertance
l'esprit libéral du rédacteur de la loi
de 1905 un esprit dont aristide-briand
temedt a résumé la vérité dans cette
phrase d'ailleurs que le président du
sénat lui même reprend à l'envi et
j'aimerais citer à nouveau ce ce mot la
loi doit protéger la foi aussi longtemps
que la foi ne prétend pas dicter la loi
et c'est la première partie de cette
phrase sur laquelle j'aimerais insister
non pas la seconde parce que la foi
protestante où la foi juive n'ont jamais
prétendu dicter la loi dans ce pays
la loi doivent protéger la foi et c'est
ce devoir de protection et d'assurance
de la liberté de culte auquel je
voudrais vous rendre attentif à nouveau
mais vous l'êtes déjà je le sais alors
que l'objectif visé est de rendre
attrayant la loi de 1905
en la surveillant la bride on la
contrôle et par conséquent au bout du
compte c'est la liberté même du culte
qui est touchée et je dois vous avouer
qu'en venant ce matin je me suis dit que
c'est la première fois comme président
de la fédération protestante de france
que je me trouve dans cette situation de
défendre la liberté de culte
je n'avais jamais imaginé que dans mon
propre pays
une chose pareille puisse arriver ici le
citoyen que je suis aussi le citoyen
d'autres pays environnants et des
chrétiens d'autres pays environnants
s'étonne et s'inquiète
pourquoi pourquoi
protestants et juifs sont ils visaient à
ce point dans ce projet de loi qui
précisément vivent dans le respect
renforcée des principes de la république
depuis 115 ans au nom de quoi
pourquoi sur certains points revenir en
arrière et monsieur roch vous dira en
quoi pourquoi sur d'autres a ajouté des
mesures
il sera aussi très précis là-dessus
pourquoi sur d'autres enfin empêcher la
gestion même des biens au mépris de
l'égalité des traitements des
associations entre entre elles
en 1901 1905 comme si l'on soupçonnait
d'enrichissement les cultes alors qu'il
s'agit dans cette histoire de gestion de
biens simplement de la capacité à
exercer le culte
après l' alerte donc l'intelligence
collective mais là je ne veux pas être
trop long parce que nous sommes tous
intelligents dans dans ce pays et donc
il essaie il s'agit de de se dire que
nous devons être attentifs à ce que nous
discours ne stigmatise pas tel ou tel et
en particulier l'islam en l'occurrence
que vous entendrez tout à l'heure je
pense par la voix de monsieur monsieur
mousserie je sais que certains dans ce
pays critiques
les évangéliques par exemple sans
vraiment les connaître d'ailleurs mais
c'est uniquement nous le savons bien
pour qu'on ne les accuse pas d'être
seulement anti musulman et il ya donc
une instrumentalisation au fond de ce
discours anti chrétiens ou entier ranger
league pour se dédouaner de cette
accusation d' islamophobie
quand les évangéliques sont très
attentifs et suivre cette audition
d'autant plus que la fédération
protestante en accord avec eux les
représentent les représente tous nos
problèmes donc le problème donc ça n'est
ni les évangéliques ni les musulmans
mais bien la capacité de notre pays à se
doter d'une loi qui conviennent aux
recettes loi de 1905 convient et s'il
faut la notte l'amendé c'est pour
qu'elle soit encore plus habitable et
non pas repoussante l'intelligence
collective donc au service de l'intérêt
général doit penser à demain et
j'aimerais j'aimerais imaginez que
demain nous ne regretterons parce que
nous sommes en train de fabriquer
maintenant
au plan au plan de la préservation de la
liberté de culte
voilà le je voulais dire enfin pour
terminer mon propos qui est bien
évidemment le protestantisme est tout à
fait en phase avec l'idée qu'il faut
lutter contre le projet politique du
radicalisme islamique
il n'y a pas de l'ambiguïté sur ce sujet
là il s'agit simplement de ne pas se
tromper de cible ni de moyens les
propositions donc vous les entendrez
tout à l'heure dans la bouche de
monsieur roch pour ce qui concerne la
promesse républicaine
enfin je voulais juste vous dire que
cette promesse reste évidemment
inaccompli comme souvent les promesses
mais qu'elle est extraordinaire et
qu'elle offre à chacun la liberté de
culte précisément la liberté
d'expression dans ce pays et à ceux qui
voudraient confondre laïcité et
neutralisation religieuses de la société
je me dois de leur rappeler que voilà
les religions sont des ressources et que
dans ce pays nous avons la chance
extraordinaire qu'elle s'entende qu'elle
se côtoient qu'elles sont fraternelles
entre elles
je vous invite d'ailleurs si vous avez
quelques loisirs dans vos nombreux
travaux à vous brancher sur le site de
la fédération à midi parce que vous
aurez là l'occasion de visionner les
voeux de la fédération au cours desquels
s'exprime justement monseigneur moulin
de beaufort pour la conférence des
évêques de france
monsieur mohamed moussaoui président du
cfcm
le grand rabbin de france rahim korcia
olivan gagnent président de l'union
bouddhiste de france renseignerait
manuel président de l'association des
évêques orthodoxes de france d'en haut
fond une un entremêlement des voeux des
religions aux religions et à la société
française dans un esprit de fraternité
et ses voeux ses voeux de nouvelle année
après une année 2009 un bien compliqué
est tellement douloureuse ses voeux
j'aimerais vous les adresser à vous et
vous les faire partager dans la
certitude que vous saurez entendre notre
plaidoyer
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président nous assurerons merci monsieur
le président bonjour mesdames et
messieurs l'objet premier de la loi est
vaste mais nous vous proposons ce matin
de nous entretenir principalement du
titre 2 qui a trait à l'exercice du
culte pourront répondre à des questions
sur le titre mais c'est peut-être sur le
titre deux que nous avons des idées les
plus spécifiques titre 2 qui nous
concerne directement
il est important de savoir que sur les
5000 association cultuelle qui existe
actuellement en france on estime mais il
n'y a pas de décompte officiel qu entre
3500 et 4000 sont des associations
cultuelles protestante pour ça que nous
sommes directement concernés par la
question et nous permettons de rappeler
ce qui nous a frappés dans l'examen de
ce titre 2 c'est l'accumulation des
mesures restrictives des contraintes
supplémentaires et ses accumulations qui
va donc peser sur tous les bénévoles
puisque dans le protestantisme tout
chaque association est animée et
conduite par des bénévoles
cette association qui s'est nouvelles
contraintes qui vont peser sur tous ces
bénévoles nous n'arrivons pas
à comprendre en quoi ça permettra de
diminuer le terrorisme ou les excès du
séparative deux objectifs dont nous
comprenons tout à fait qu'on veuille
lutter contre mais nous ne voyons pas du
tout en quoi ces deux objectifs nous
cancer donc nombreuses démarches et non
seulement ses nombreuses démarches vont
demander du travail tant aux bénévoles
qu'aux services préfectoraux
auront-ils le personnel pour étudier
nous ne posons pas la question en vain
faut pas oublier que le régime qui est
proposée déjà existé en france de 1988 à
2007 il ce régime avait montré son
inutilité puisque justement les
préfectures soient n'avait pas le
personnage soit considéré qu'elle avait
d'autres priorités que d'étudier des
dossiers
et puis ensuite une question toute
simple il est demandé
chaque fois qu'on crée une cultuel de
déposer un dossier pour que le préfet
puisse vérifier qu'elle est bien
cultuelle chacun sait qu'il est simple
de faire un dossier qu'il soit bon c'est
la réalité qui peut permettre de faire
apparaître des non respect des lois de
non respect des statuts et c'est donc
signifie la l'établissement d'un dossier
initial avant toute action
c'est d'ailleurs cet argument même qui
était utilisé par les préfets pour dire
nous avons bien reçu vos dossiers mais
il n'y a pas de l'étudier donc pourquoi
recréer cette contrainte alors que
l'expérience a montré qu'elle était
inutile et une fois que l'association
existe le préfet n'est pas dénué à
l'heure actuelle des moyens
d'information
d'une part si l'association reçoit des
libéralités nécessairement un dossier
est constitué et c'est le cas et dont le
préfet à toute information sur la
réalité
d'autre part les qu'on doit être envoyée
chaque année et donc le préfet a toute
liberté
s'il apparaît au fait qu'il ya des
événements répréhensible nous ne
contestons pas la possibilité
il a tous les moyens d'intervenir donc
par rapport à la situation actuelle nous
ne comprenons pas pourquoi on serait
obligés d'augmenter ses contraintes et
surtout ce que ça apporterait à l'état
pour le moment nous n'avons pas eu de
réponse à des observations
pour vous donner un autre exemple il est
prévu également un contrôle des fonds
venant de l'étranger
si cela est important c'est à vous de le
décider
mais si cela était important
pourquoi ne l'appliquer qu'aux sommes
reçues par les associations cultuelles
alors que tous les articles de presse et
même les rapports de bercy montre que
les hommes venant d'étrangers arrive
demain tu le montant beaucoup plus
important dans le domaine sportif et
dans le domaine culturel
donc si c'est un problème pour la
république il faut le traiter dans tous
ses aspects et non pas dans uniquement
ce petit aspect parce que soyons clairs
c'est un petit aspect pour nous ou de
cette question de principe
il ya une question pratique vous savez
bien que lorsque on a un commissaire aux
comptes
on doit le garder pendant six ans j'en
viens à dire prenant l'exemple d'une
association cultuelle sur un budget de
50 mille euros par an 50 mille euros par
an n'a pas besoin de commissaire au camp
qui auraient besoin de refaire son toit
et qui recevrait à cet effet 15000 euros
d'une église américaine prend un exemple
exprès américaine pourrait être hors de
l'union européenne
eh bien elle serait obligée pendant six
ans puis un commissaire aux comptes qui
lui coûterait plus cher que les 15000
euros reçus et je vois toujours pas
pourquoi parce que une idée américaine
aura soutenu une paroisse rurale pour
refaire son toit ça pose un problème à
la république française
donc je crois qu'il ya toute une série
d'exemples concrets qui mérite d'être
connue pour on se demande quel est
l'objectif au-delà de toutes ces
questions pratiques et on pourrait
donner d'autres exemples
il faut quand même se poser aussi une
question de fond pourquoi existe-t-il le
régime spécifique des associations
cultuelles cette question elle a été
posée en 1905 et un grand débat savoir
s'il fallait en créer ou non si un
régime spécifique a été créé c'était
parce que l'état ou plutôt non pas
l'état justement mais les établissements
publics du culte appelé être dissous
allait donner leurs biens aux cultuelle
ce n'est pas l'état qui a fait le
transfert ce sont les établissements et
c'est à cause de cette exception voulue
par le parlement qui ont été créés un
régime particulier mais cet argument
n'est valable que pour les associations
qui ont reçu des biens c'est à dire les
associations qui existait en 1906 et qui
ont reçu des biens ce associations on
connaît le nom mais n'a à peu près se
dire des biens qui appartiennent en
particulier soit aux établissements
publics soit qu'ils appartiennent encore
aux communes qui sont affectés au culte
c'est une situation
athée fini donc qu'est ce qui justifie
que pour toutes les associations créées
après 1906 qui n'ont jamais reçu et qui
ne bénéficient pas de biens appartenant
aux collectivités territoriales y ait de
telles règles
ce n'est pas une question nouvelle le
chef de cabinet d'aristide briand
l'avait déjà posé à l'époque il avait
dit ce que nous faisons est justifiée
maintenant ne le sera plus demain
la question est là étaient posées je n'a
pas eu de réponse mais où nous
permettant de la reposer en 2021
qu'est ce qui justifie ces règles pour
des associations qui n'ont pas de bien b
appartenant à la collectivité publique
alors on nous donne parfois un second
argument les avantages des associations
cultuelles et c'est vrai que la loi de
1905 quand elle a été votée comporter
une liste de recettes beaucoup plus
étendue que la loi 1901
c'est indiscutable mais heureusement
depuis 1905 tout ce qui pouvait
constituer un avantage pour une cultuel
a été étendue à toutes les associations
d'intérêt général ce qui fait que ces
avantages n'existe plus à part un seul
celui de pouvoir disposer de biens
appartenant collectivités territoriales
ça c'est un avantage qui existent encore
mais qui existe de manière très
diversifiés puisqu'il est de 90% pour
l'église catholique de 12% pour les
églises protestantes de 3% pour les
juifs et 2 0% pour tous les autres
cultes qui fait que nous reposons la
question qu'est ce qui justifie que pour
toutes ces institutions qui ne
bénéficient d'aucun avantage et directs
supplémentaires alors le troisième
argument qu'on trouve dans l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi
c'est que les associons cultuelle comme
c'est écrit sur les lieux tous en nous
proviennent toute une série de mesures
qui portent atteinte à la république
soyons concrets et prenant les chiffres
que nous propose l'étude d'impact études
et pâques dit actuellement il est
possible c'est pas obligatoire c'est
possible de demander un rescrit qu'on
appelle administratif 608 ont été
déposées l'an dernier
sur ses six ans 8 combien ont été
refusées d'après le projet d'un d'étude
d'impact par les préfets
un sur 608 a été refusée pour un motif
d'ordre public moins de 2 pour mille
est ce que le fait qu'il ya eu moins de
2 pour mille contre venant justifie
également toutes ces mesures et ces
questions que nous posons avec une
certaine insistance que voudrait bien
excuser nous n'avons toujours pas eu de
réponse
depuis nous depuis trois mois que nous
les posons voilà donc c'est vraiment ces
questions de fond qui nous paraissent
importants et ce que nous attendons ce
que nous espérons c'est que ces
questions étant prises en compte toutes
les contraintes que l'on multiplie dans
le projet à l'encontre des associations
soit ou appliquer à toutes celles qui
sont concernées
il n'y a pas que les notes ou au
contraire atténuée je vous remercie
merci monsieur bien je vais donner la
parole à nos rapporteur je sais pas qui
d'entre elles ou s'ils ont des questions
pas mettez vous d'accord mais madame
lesage réunion n'a pas de merci merci
merci à vous messieurs
bon on a bien compris j'ai bien compris
en tout cas je parle pour moi
globalement c'est l'hostilité que vous
avez par rapport à ce texte pour
différentes raisons que vous avez
expliqué voilà qui vous appartiennent
si ce texte est là c'est que je le pense
sincèrement qu'il fait il répond à une
difficulté que notre pays a je pense que
être dans le déni la difficulté que nous
avons aujourd'hui à régler et pour les
cas les solutions ne sont pas simples
serait dommage parce que je pense que
nous n'avancerons pas pour faire en
sorte que ce pays ne se fracturent pas
en tout cas moi je fais partie de ces
élus qui pensent que nous devons tout
faire pour éviter les fractures dans
notre pays est en tout cas faire en
sorte que les gens ne disent pas les uns
en face des autres mais les uns avec les
autres
c'est à mon avis l'un des objectifs de
ce texte qui pourrait être intéressant
de poser
nous vous avez rappelé à juste titre que
la loi protège la fois mais la loi
s'impose aussi à la fois ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut peut-être
oubliée et que la liberté de culte ne me
semble pas remise en cause dans un texte
quel qu'il soit même si il doit être
travaillée retravaillée discuter vous
avez eu des propos qui précisait que ce
texte stigmatiser une partie de la
population
moi j'aurais envie de dire qu' elle met
au jour cette somme à ce texte met au
jour une réalité d'une petite partie de
la population qu'il convient en tout cas
de regarder avec courage et avec
détermination parce que on ne lui c'est
vrai que nous avons un problème avec
l'islamisme il faut voilà c'est une
réalité que beaucoup de gens
reconnaissent et avec tristesse est
tristement qui ne concerne évidemment
pas tous les musulmans tout le monde le
sait tous qu'on le dit et tout le monde
le voit là et qu'il faut bien trouver
des outils et des moyens pour faire en
sorte que toutes ces difficultés que
nous avons à gérer puisse avoir une
espèce de cohérence alors vous avez
parlé d'un certain nombre de choses qui
vous gêne vous monsieur en particulier
sur le contrôle les associations le
contrôle des fonds c'est un vrai sujet
alors évidemment tout le monde n'est pas
concerné de la même manière évidemment
évidemment mais il ya obligatoire
l'objet d'un objectif d'égalité dans ce
que nous devons mettre en place
on peut pas dire c'est bien pour les uns
c'est mauvais pour les autres ça je
pense que ensemble on peut en convenir
ça me paraît important donc vous avez
effectivement parler de contraintes
parler de ce qui vous gêne au niveau du
commissaire en contre mais il faut bien
que l'état trouve des outils et des
moyens qui s'inscrivent dans le respect
de chacun mais dans les obligations de
chacun aussi ça ça me paraît important
donc clairement aujourd'hui pour faire
face à ces voix là ses soucis que nous
avons d'organisation un petit peu
parfois compliquée d'un culte quelles
sont vos propositions parce que l'état
attend des choses nous nous attendons
des choses pour pouvoir passer à autre
chose pour que les choses soient claires
en dehors de choses qui vous gêne
quelles seraient vos propositions qui
pourraient objectivement aider
bah et l'état mais pas que l'état parce
que c'est pas les tasses et c'est la
france dont on parle et c'est l'unité de
la france dont on parle aujourd'hui
voilà clairement qu est-ce qui vous
satisferait parce qu'il ya un problème
il ya un problème ce qui est proposé
vous convient pas et donc du coup qu'est
ce que vous pourriez proposé et qui vous
conviendrait pour pouvoir atteindre les
objectifs communs que nous avons merci
alors à temps mais n'avaient rien merci
je reviendrai donc pas sur tout le
développement de ma collègue je vais
vous poser des questions plus pratiques
puisque on rentre dans le texte tout
juste comme la présidente président vous
parlez de contraintes sur les bénévoles
s'agit-il par exemple de la vérifier que
ils sont aussi j'ai tout quel autre
contrainte
y aurait-il
et d'ailleurs si c'est le cas je pense
qu'on pourra vous annoncer dans les
années qui viennent d'autres contraintes
notamment je pense sur les violences
sexuelles
le fait que les bénévoles soient
également contrôlé donc je pense que
c'est pas fini
vous parlez bon des commissaires aux
comptes ça j'ai bien saisi le 15 mille
euros et le fait que le commissaire aux
comptes est là pour six ans par contre
dans vos réponses vous parler de la
difficulté et oui vous l'avez abordé de
la gestion des immeubles de rapport
qu'est ce qui change dans la loi qui
fait que vous ne pouvez plus ou au
contraire vous pourriez peut-être mieux
le faire bien je propose de voter la
parole tout de suite et puis ensuite je
prendrai d'autres questions c'est lui
qui le souhaitent naturellement c'est
vrai nom je vais juste faire non pas une
réponse
enfin juste une voilà une prolongation
de réflexion à la suite des propos de
madame moustache pris nos 6 6 dans la
société française une communauté n'est
pas dans le déni c'est bien la
communauté protestante je veux dire on
va pas se se soupçonner les uns les
autres de déni c'est un mot d'ailleurs
qui
qui a des connotations là qui n'ont rien
à voir avec le débat d'aujourd'hui nous
sommes bien d'accord pour travailler
pour l'unité pour la concorde de ce pays
et le protestantisme en a fait la preuve
depuis depuis qu'il est là ce que je
veux dire c'est que les propositions
puisque vous avez fait appel à ce terme
les propositions que nous faisons et que
nous que nous souhaitons sont des
propositions qui doivent pouvoir
permettre à l'islam précisément de
trouver sa place dans ce pays
une place qui n'a pas encore trouvé et
le motif de ce projet de loi est un
indice de cette recherche c'est pour ça
que ce n'est pas le projet en tant que
tel que nous remettons en cause mais
bien un certain nombre de ces mesures
ne nous trompons pas de sujet et si
aujourd'hui nous constatons que la
majorité des associations musulmanes
sont en 1901 en 1907
c'est bien parce que ça ne va pas et
c'est bien parce qu'elles n'ont pas
trouvé dans le cadre 1905
de quoi exercer pleinement le culte et
dans le dialogue que nous avons parce
que nous ne dialoguons nous sommes dans
la concorde et la fraternité dans le
dialogue que nous avons avec nos amis du
culte musulman d'ailleurs de quelques
fédérations qu'il soit
nous constatons une réelle hésitations
devant ce projet parce que rien ne les
encourage à venir en 1905
rien et comme nous nous sommes les
gardiens du temple si je peux me
permettre cette expression concernant
cette loi
nous sommes fort déçu enfin nous sommes
en attente on aimerait bien que
justement les choses changent et que ce
qui avait été annoncé à savoir que cette
loi deviendrai attrayante pour justement
après une contrainte plus fortes à
l'égard de la 1900 et en 1907
7 cette loi devenue accueillante de
deviennent vraiment le lieu d'expression
du culte musulman ce ce projet ne
fonctionne pas là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes en train de faire
ses propositions pour justement voilà
dire c'est possible allons-y ensemble cc
c'est cela que je veux dire c'est c'est
c'est dans cet esprit-là que nous
exprimons ce n'est pas du tout dans un
esprit de d'obstruction c'est dans un
esprit au contraire de construction pour
permettre que à la fois les diocésaine
on va dire et les cultuelle soit les
lieux habituels de l'expression de la
religion dans ce pays d'ailleurs la
république à l'époque j'ai dit à
l'époque
je n'y étais pas mais a été suffisamment
souple alors même que ce alors ça je le
sais depuis très peu de temps grâce à
monsieur roch alors même que la
conférence des évêques de l'époque avait
accepté le projet de loi 1905 rome ayant
refusé la république a été suffisamment
souple et sage pour pour permettre la
fabrication d'un statut sur mesure et ça
a été l'association de sézanne donc je
dire voilà il s'agit il s'agit d'avancer
ensemble et dans la concorde et non pas
dans la confrontation et donc de se
donner les moyens juridiques pour que
chacun puisse vraiment vivre cette
liberté de culte et je termine en disant
que la liberté de culte n'est donc pas
une pétition de principe
c'est quelque chose qui se traduit par
des textes qui permettent l'expression
de la liberté de culte
d'où les questions matérielles concrètes
très précises que nous posons merci le
superflu choc
oui nous ne sommes pas du tout pour
continuer hostile à des contraintes nous
les connaissons nous appliquons et je
veux dire nous n'avons pas de
difficultés pour appliquer les
contraintes tout ce que nous demandons
c'est une contrainte soit justifiée et
proportionnée et il ya quand même un
million cinq cent mille associations en
france nous n'avons nous avons peine à
comprendre pourquoi un contrôle accru
sur 5000 résoudrait tous les problèmes
de la république c'est pour ça que s'il
ya des mesures à prendre
nous avons bien dit si nous ne disons
pas il n'ya pas mais s'il ya des mesures
à prendre pour quoi ne viser que sam
hill sur un million cinq cent mille ça
c'est quand même notre première question
est proportionné également parce que les
associations cultuelles en tout cas pour
les protestante
j'aurais tendance à penser que ça doit
être pareil pour les juifs sont
également entièrement animés par des
bénévoles donc il s'agit pas de crainte
regardez personnes des bénévoles qui se
relève tout de la loi et nous sommes
tous attentifs à toutes les dispositions
matière civile pénale etc
aucune contestation la matière mais en
matière de travail à faire pour faire
des dossiers qui ont plus nous l'avons
expérimenté puisque je le redis le
dispostif qui est proposé il a existé
pendant 20 ans ne servait à rien
qu'on prenne des mesures utiles nous
n'avons jamais contesté qu'il en soit
ainsi
mais des mesures utiles et pas des
mesures qui vont directement aux
archives départementales
car c'est ce qui s'est passé quand le
régime existe et donc ça insiste
là-dessus c'est pas la contrainte qui
nous fait réagir c'est la contrainte
inutile et qui n'est pas proportionnée
la question de semaines de rapport est
une excellente question
config en scène les difficultés de votre
métier de législateurs 2901 à 2014
la question était simple aucune
association ne pouvait avoir deviendra
pas sauf quelques exceptions prévues par
la loi
bon et la règle générale s'était pas
d'immeubles de rapport en 2014 la loi de
1901 a été modifiée mais elle s'applique
aussi aux mutuelles et elle a permis les
immeubles de rapport
sauf aux associations qui existent le
culte est une phrase qui est subtile
puisqu'il faut savoir que elle permet
aux petits b du 1 de l'article 200 et
que les cultuelle sont au petit peu du 1
de l'article 200 dans ça c'est pas
évident quand on lit la loi mais quand
on les connaît la loi les seuls exclus
sans les cultuelle
cette loi a été votée promulguée et
appliquées par des préfets qui du coup
constatant un certain nombre de
situations se sont mis à contester la
qualité de cultuelles et les situations
qu'ils ont compté c'est donnant un
exemple concret une paroisse qui a eu un
temps de pasteur qui n'a plus qu'un
temporairement
qui donc vu les demandes de logement
loup le second presbytère le préfet lui
dit et le préfet il applique la loi
telle qu'elle est écrite vous n'avez pas
le droit de louer le second presbytère
et c'est parce que nous avons eu
plusieurs de ces problèmes depuis 2015
dans ses dents lien direct avec la loi
2014 que nous disons il ya une question
à régler à ce conseil est venue
s'ajouter la demande d'avoir des revenus
qui permet de se passer des fonds qui
arrivent de l'étranger
ça c'est venu après jeudi indépendamment
de ce second motif que nous ne nions pas
il y avait le premier motif
voilà pourquoi nous demandons que tout
simplement la loi générale qui permet à
toute association qui existe depuis
trois ans d'avoir des immeubles de
rapport
ce puisse être appliqué aussi aux
associations cultuelles n'ont pas
mais nous aussi nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi ces permis à tout le monde sauf
à nous merci alors je vais dès la parole
pour des questions madame brigitte
lherbier madame esther benbassa et
madame marie mercier
oui monsieur le président merci c'est
plutôt une remarque qu'une question
monsieur le pasteur clavero lit j'ai
ressenti dans vos propos une sorte de de
rancoeur de je sais pas j'ai eu un
sentiment de doute et surtout je tenais
à prendre la parole pour dire que ce
n'est pas du tout le but de cette de ce
texte
vous savez un à lille tous les ans
depuis trente ans on se réunit avec les
élus et tous les membres de chaque culte
que ça soit le rabbin que ça soit le le
pasteur le recteur la mosquée tout le
monde se réunit régulièrement sur des
thèmes d'actualité avec un regard aussi
un regard sur les sources de réflexions
des uns et des autres les sources
religieuses et on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
forcément des divergences des façons de
penser différente c'est très instructif
ce genre de réunions parce que on
s'aperçoit qu'on a une culture qui peut
être sensiblement
divergent pourquoi pas et je pense que
ses avocats depuis 30 ans ont réussi à
montrer qu' il y avait des choses à
régler
les élus montrent leur leurs difficultés
dans les quartiers ou autre et je peux
vous assurer que on sent sur le terrain
une a besoin de trouver une solution et
je pensais et ma collègue jacqueline
eustache brinio le souligner il y avait
un besoin il faut qu'on y répondre et
surtout n'ayez aucune sensation de
d'être visé particulièrement le
président et merci pour les informations
que vous nous apportez et de même je
constate que vous mettez l'accent sur
les relations intercommunautaires
elle ce qui est quand même très
important et les médias n'en parlent pas
assez souvent parce que c'est c'est un
terreau relations elles font avancer les
religions et on sait qu'on n'a jamais
changé une religion par le haut mais
qu'on a toujours changé les religions
par le bas dans le dialogue avec la
population et les personnes intéressées
et excusez moi de faire une comparaison
elle est peut-être audacieuse mais
toutefois je me demande
ainsi on assiste actuellement à une
sorte concordat mini concordat comme
celui de napoléon n'est ce pas
sous la peau les os est là
avec des retombées assez important
puisque on sait que la religion et qui
est visé peut-être parce que cette
religion a besoin aussi d'être réformé
d'avancé de de se mettre au rythme de
des autres religions dans un occident
qui se présentent aux musulmans un peu
tard dix ont massivement ils l'ont été
en france qu'à partir des années 1970 ce
même si leur présence est attestée
bien avant cette religion a besoin
d'être réformé mais on a l'impression
que ce qu'on fasse cette réforme
concerne d'abord l'islam et les autres
religions ont été dix ont introduit dans
cette sorte de désir de réformes à tout
prix coûte que coûte et que probablement
le judaïsme et le protestantisme et le
catholicisme se débrouille très bien
sans cette réforme depuis longtemps et
ai vu leur expérience
qui n'est pas nouvelle et aussi disons
que ces religions elles sont passées par
le concordat pas l'islam maintenant trop
tard
elle n'a pas eu droit au concordat enfin
c'est pas que je fasse l'éloge du
concordat mais alors au moins on se pose
une question pourquoi les autres
religions sont touchées on veut de
réformer l'islam et on essaie de toucher
aussi aux institutions ou disons au
développement n'est de ces religions
dans sans problème jusque là et on se
demande en quoi
lorsque vous allez changer votre système
associatif étudiants en quoi on va
combattre le terrorisme
ça c'est ma question première et moi je
suis une enseignante
l'objectif est d'abord de former les
imams et c'est là que commencent les
choses et on n'a jamais attaqué ce sujet
parce que il est trop délicat on peut
les former en terre concordataire moi
même j'ai été professeur à l'école
pratique des hautes études où on a les
grands spécialistes des religions et
aussi de l'islam
on aurait pu prendre les formations qui
existent déjà à la mosquée de paris et
ailleurs et compléter cela par des
cursus spécifique l'université et public
ne fait pas de la théologie il faut que
nos dirigeants comprennent qu'il ya la
théologie et les le savoir républicain
le les savoirs classiques des sciences
humaines etc
alors voilà là on est un peu dans une
impasse à mon modeste avis et je crains
que tout cela n'aboutisse mois si on
commence pas tout simplement pas la
formation des imams
voilà je suis chez moi d'avoir été
longue
merci madame merci merci merci monsieur
le président oui monsieur le pasteur
donc il ne reste que trois choses la foi
l'espérance et la charité mais nous
avons quand même l'espérance
alors on a bien entendu vos propos avec
toutes les réticences qui sont qui sont
dans ce texte de loi
donc est ce que vous pensez quand même
pas qu'il ya quelques bonnes choses dans
ce texte est je pense à l'engagement
l'engagement républicain qui est exigé
pour toutes les associations qui sut
kiki ce moment solliciter une subvention
publique donc est ce que dans ce texte
de voix on peut sauver quelque chose ou
alors est ce que c'est vraiment inutile
voire dangereux bien je propose
peut-être de répondre à cette première
cette question et ensuite j'ai deux
autres demandes d'intervention oui très
très très rapidement mais je vous
remercie beaucoup pour ces questions
d'abord j'aimerais m'adresser à madame
qui avait fait référence à l'île aux
noix pourquoi j'ai été douze ans en
pasteur dans cette ville que je connais
bien et j'ai eu vrai dès les années
enfin 80 90 a justement ce ce tissage
des relations entre les communautés je
suis très heureux que tout ça fleuriste
continue se sent ici c'est vraiment on
est dans cette de cette dynamique
voilà donc la promesse républicaine vaut
aussi pour les cultes et c'est très bien
ainsi
madame benbassa je partage que vous
venez de dire vraiment et je suis très
heureux d'entendre ce propos ici avec la
pointe fine concernant la formation des
imams parce qu'effectivement il ya un an
je vous savez que la formation des
cadres religieux est un enjeu alors pour
les protestants depuis la réforme la
réforme menée à l'université 1
elle n'est à l'université donc ce sont
des profs d'université qui deviennent
les premiers leaders de ce mouvement et
puis ce sont des pasteurs formé à
l'université qui exercent dans les
communautés donc c'est cette attention à
la formation des cadres et pour nous
aussi très très importante et je vous
remercie de l'avoir souligné j'espère
effectivement nous trouverons des
solutions pour les musulmans pour les
imams et les cas d'impasse il n'y a pas
que les imams il y a aussi les les
les responsables de communautés qui
doivent être formés et là je pense que
l'école pratique des hautes études
l'université ont leur mot à dire leur
part à prendre dans cette formation
mais voilà qu'elle quel système je me
souviens quand j'étais à strasbourg que
étudiants étudiants laurier ça remonte à
mathusalem
le président l'universel d'époque
le président de l'université de l'époque
etienne troquenet avait proposé que
voilà on crée à côté de la faculté de
théologie protestante data les giclées
et théologie catholique une faculté de
théologie protestante musulmane
on était en 1977 c'était quand même hier
si vous voulez ça n'a jamais abouti mais
voilà il ya des modèles peut être
inventé peut-être pas celui là pour pour
ce qui concerne le le contrat
d'engagement et public un pour qui un
contrat il faut qu'il y ait deux
contractants la loi va imposer à gérer
les associations sont pas contractantes
l'a donc ce mot de contrat à mes yeux
est un petit peu surévalué la loi
propose un engagement république a ôté
un engagement mais cet engagement
toutes les associations le portent
toutes les associations qui sont sous le
régime 1900 porte cet engagement les
associations du protestantisme en tout
cas mais celle du catholicisme aussi
qu'ils sont engagés sur les questions de
l'extrême pauvreté du handicap de
l'exclusion de l'accueil de l'étranger
etc
du soin toutes ces associations sont
déjà dans cet engagement républicain et
des haies et des respect de la sécurité
des respect de la loi donc ok on est
bien dans le renforcement des principes
républicains
mais j'allais dire on n'est que là on
n'est que là ça ne va pas changer la
donne fondamentalement donc c'est bon je
le faut le garder si vous voulez je veux
bien mais mais ça ne change pas la donne
fondamentalement c'est ça que je veux
dire et peut-être même que ça met une
pression jaillir un peu inutile comme
s'il y avait un soupçon là encore sur
ces associations qui serait
dans l'incapacité de vivre la république
mais quoi pour qui prend ton ces
associations voient la ccem
je suis pas dans la rancoeur du tout je
suis dans l'interrogation républicaine
quand le président de la république
parle d'une société de confiance et de
vigilance
j'entends j'entends que la confiance
soit vraiment soit vraiment reçu est
partagé par tous même si heures une
remarque est une question remarque
monsieur président et monsieur le
conseiller juridique
je trouve important la façon dont vous
avez posé la question d'emblée
quel est le problème et en quoi le
changement juridique du statut d'une
partie des associations ou des
associations peut régler le problème
et peut-on distinguer entre les
associations
il ya là des questions utiles quand nous
rencontrerons par exemple les membres du
gouvernement je pense que vous les avez
posé directement une question maintenant
après ce constat j'ai lu le dernier
livre de monsieur candiard sur le
fanatisme willy finalement pour lutter
contre le fanatisme
il faut mieux connaître la réalité des
religions et la question est simple on a
parlé
madame benbassa parler de la formation
des imams mais plus généralement comment
voyez-vous dans l'enseignement public
laïc ce important laïque
le fait de favoriser la connaissance du
fait religieux pour éviter les toutes
les dérives toutes les incompréhensions
tous les fanatismes toutes les
récupérations dans le respect de la
laïcité tueur
monsieur le comte et ensuite madame
gatel oui merci monsieur le président et
merci à nos deux ainsi monsieur le
président je voudrais dans beaucoup de
pays du monde
l'appartenance on parle d' appartenance
à une communauté religieuse ça fait
partie de l'identité
je pense que la loi de 1905 a
profondément transformé notre pays de ce
point de vue là je pense que nous étions
dans une situation où l'appartenance à
une communauté religieuse faisait partie
de l'identité
c'est probablement beaucoup moins le cas
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas comment vous
vous concevez est-ce que vous concevez
comme représentant d'une communauté ou
représentants finalement de personnes
qui partagent la même démarche
spirituelle et pensez vous comment
comment accompagner finalement ceux qui
dans notre pays se considère comme une
communauté pour être finalement pas une
communauté en tant que tel mais
finalement une communauté de conviction
pas une communauté d'identité merci
monsieur le comte
madame françoise gatel merci monsieur le
président merci beaucoup
messieurs pour votre intervention
je voudrais à la fois donner un peu un
sentiment et vous et vous interroger sur
ce texte qui perturbe totalement ceux et
celles qui sont dans le respect des
principes républicains qui jouissent
d'une liberté que la loi l'ordre
toutefois aujourd'hui on voit bien que
notre société les bousculer par certains
qui usent de cette liberté pour un usage
qui n'est pas un usage religieux mais
qui est un usage de prosélytisme à
l'encontre de la société et que cette
société
elle est amenée à un moment à revisiter
un peu ses fondamentaux pour se protéger
parce que les choses ont bougé alors
j'entends vos réserves j'entends vos
observations que je ne conteste pas du
tout quand vous dites monsieur mais nous
nous faisons tout cela quand on répond à
la question de marie mercier sur
l'engagement républicain et à quoi bon
nous demander tout cela alors même que
l'état ne pourra pas contrôler je devais
prendre une comparaison avec ce qui
s'est passé sur l'enseignement privé
hors contrat ou certaines religions qui
ont des établissements scolaires
d'obédience religieuse disait mais tout
cela nous le faisons en rien une
enfreignant la loi et donc matichon est
simple
monsieur quand une société confrontée à
de très grands dangers qui ne faut pas
sous-estimer qu'il ne faut pas non plus
surestimer quand elle demande à chacun
d'affirmer le respect des principes
républicains qu'il est au delà de la
gêne mais quelle est la difficulté pour
ceux qui comme vous la respecte déjà
d'accepter ce que j'appellerais de la
transparence d'afficher des choses alors
même que je pense que tout cela peut
protéger les religions dans une société
extrêmement on va dire éruptive je vous
remercie
mais si un gars tel monsieur le
président monsieur monsieur roch
oui je tiens à remercier monsieur suaire
pour sa question qui se trouve me
m'intéresse ce profondément puisque j'ai
été pendant 25 ans proviseur d'un lycée
public avant d'être responsable des
programmes de l'établissement des
programmes promis syndicales nationales
dans c'est une question effectivement
fondamentale qui est soulevée depuis
plus de trente années on est obligé de
constater la méconnaissance croissante
de nos élèves à tous les niveaux sur les
constituants de notre société y compris
les constituants religieux mais pas que
les constituants redis j'ai d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des constituants notre
société et cette méconnaissance
croissante des élèves renvoi il faut le
reconnaître et l'inspection générale a
toujours reconnu à celle des enseignants
c'est clair c'est clair et il ya un
rapport qui avait été fait qui explique
et la nécessité de développer
l'enseignement du fait religieux
le choix qui a été retenu c'était de ne
pas créer une matière nouvelle ce qui
peut tout à fait se comprendre non on
est bien obligé de constater
que ce choix là a conduit à ce qu'il ya
un certain nombre d'établissements où il
ya des activités effectives qui
permettent de mieux connaître les faits
religieux
il faut pas dire ça n'existe nulle part
ça existe parfois mais c'est très
lacunaire c'est quelques établissements
en france et c'est effectivement un
problème majeur qui est certainement à
l'origine des difficultés et de nos
concitoyens et de tout le contrôle de
ses concitoyens je crois que c'est une
question fondamentale et mais hélas
c'est les religions participent à la
formation d'un geste au nom de deux
français ou d'habitants de la france
mais un nombre réduit là aussi vous le
savez également donc le seul moyen
d'arriver à une formation de l'ensemble
de la population c'est de passer par le
réseau de l'éducation nationale oui à la
question était reprise concernant
l'engagement républicain donc je réponds
à votre votre relance qui donc ikim qui
m'interpelle là aussi je vous rappelle
quand même que dans le premier texte du
projet de loi ont parlé de sauvegarde
d'ordre de l'ordre public
enfin je dis heureusement que nous
sommes intervenus parce que ce n'est
quand même pas aux associations 1902 de
préserver l'ordre public enfin je veux
dire c'est qu'on marche sur la tête
quand même là quelle qu'elle soit dans
l'ordre public oui mais qui s engagent à
la sauvegarde de l'ordre public vous
rendez compte le progrès qu'on a fait
faire heureusement que nous sommes
intervenus fait le nom et collectif le
nous n'est pas
j'allais dire personnel comme son nom l
indique est donc nous avons évolué là
dessus nous avons donc heureusement ne
fait bouger un tout petit peu le texte
sorte qu'on parle de sécurité je crois
que sur le terme de sécurité publique
qui a été qui a été retenu et c'est très
bien enfin je dirai clairement les
associations s'inscrivent dans le cadre
du respect de la sécurité publique mais
j'aimerais dire pourquoi nous sommes
nous sommes un peu ému de cela parce
qu'ouvrir comment la le législateur va
très vite là où il ne faut pas qu'il
aille il imaginer que des associations
qui demandent des subventions se voir
reprocher de ne pas avoir été à l'oeuvre
dans la sauvegarde de l'ordre public
quand elle s'occupe j'allais dire aux
frontières aux frontières c'est le cas
de le dire en frontières de la loi et
aux frontières de l'accueil des réfugiés
qui sont sans papiers qui sont
pourchassés qui n'ont donc aucune
légitimité juridique
on pourrait leur reprocher justement de
se mettre en défaut et donc refusé
refuser leur financement vous voyez
c'est c'était à ça que nous pensions
c'est le secours catholique c'est la
cimade phase est celle entraide
protestante c'est l'armée du salut même
c'est l'armée du salut vous imaginez
kiki voilà qui pourrait très bien se
trouver confronté à ce type 2
voilà donc les choses ont bougé et dans
le bon sens moi je m'en réjouis voilà
c'est ça je voulais dire pour ce qui
concerne la
la remarque sur les communautés de
conviction et d'identité j'entends bien
la distinction et elle et pas seulement
sémantique
moi je ne suis pas représentants de
communautés au sens du communautarisme
mais je ne voudrais pas non plus que ce
mot de communautés soient bannis par
leur représentation nationale faut pas
quand même non plus la exagéré dans le
sens d'une espèce de d'arasement de tout
ce qui pourrait être le regroupement de
citoyens enfin je veux dire la
communauté religieuse ça existe je ne
veux pas dire que les communautés
religieuses oeuvre au séparatisme dans
ce pays
je ne veux pas mettre en cause ça mais
quand même il faut honorer le mot de
communauté la communauté nationale et
d'une certaine manière le
l'entremêlement de différentes
communautés de conviction mais aussi
d'identité et d'identité au pluriel
donc voilà c'est ça que je voulais dire
dans réponse à votre propre au jeu nous
sommes très allants les protestants sont
très vigilant là dessus ne sont pas du
tout en position de repli
communautariste
ce sont des églises des paroisses et est
composée de citoyens chrétiens laïcs
merci michel pas dans même que queyranne
oui je vous remercie à mesure présente
d'abord vous remercier effectivement un
monsieur pour vos propos introductif
réagir par le débat et un certain nombre
de remarques de mes collègues sur la
problématique scolaire parce que je
crois que nous devons quand même toutes
et tous faire attention
chacun a ses repères dans la société
dans sa propre vie qui lui permettent de
le structurer et donc je reste convaincu
que l'école est à l'image de la société
et que ce n'est pas qu'un problème
d'enseignement j'entends ce que vous
venez de dire mais oui mon pour avoir
été enseignante précédent je ne suis pas
sûr son imposant une nouvelle matière
sur le fait religieux que nous avons le
souci
nous avons aujourd'hui une absence
totale de culture scientifique dans
notre pays il n'y aurait pas une
nouvelle matière culture scientifique a
créé alors que n'aurait interrogeant un
certain nombre de programmes mais force
est de constater que je vais prendre les
programmes d'histoire qui sont ceux que
je connais mieux malgré les évolutions
et les débats qui ont pu montrer agitée
nous avons toujours enseigné la
naissance des relais et des religions du
livre du monothéisme leur spécificité à
chacun puis les oppositions entre
celles-ci jusqu'aux guerres de religion
la saint-barthélemy etc etc
et je ne suis pas sûr que les ans soit
des enseignants ils soient mieux
préparés aujourd'hui qu'hier
la vraie difficulté à laquelle sont
confrontés les enseignants aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement d'abord un rapport à
l'école qui est vrai pour toutes les
matières ou dans l'école comme dans le
reste tout le monde sait mieux que tout
le monde
un rapport des enfants à l'autorité mais
quand je parle de l'autorité de
l'autorité éducative et intellectuel qu
incarne un enseignant voilà aujourd'hui
de toute façon on pouvait dire argumenté
de fait un certain nombre de choses
celui qui a ici qui la verrait
on sent lui aucune argumentation poids
est convaincu qu'il a raison donc moi je
vois je nuance simplement ce qu'ils
vivent ce qui vient d'être dit parce que
je ne suis pas sûr pour avoir été moins
mettre moi-même comment s'appelait
maître de stage d'un certain nombre de
jeunes collègues tout juste bénéficiaire
du concours
que l'on soit aujourd'hui mieux formés
ou mieux apparier à l'enseignement en
tant que tel par contre il est vrai que
nous avons les maux de la société qui
entre dans l'école et autant je suis
profondément attaché à la place de
l'école et de deux
mais voyez d'une école peut-être aussi
parfois un peu anciennes dans une école
qui transmet du savoir parce que ce
savoir sera justement le fondement de la
communauté républicaine et d'une école
ou un moment donné on ne débattent pas
de tout et vous remettre pas tout en
question et que oui en matière notamment
d'histoire il ya des choses qui sont
factuels et qui doivent être intégrées
par tous pour générer du commun quant au
reste l'école comme tout le reste elle
et par elle et elle est pénétrée du
meilleur et du pire de la société et
donc de pratiquer aussi religieuses qui
ont évolué de rapport à la religion qui
a évolué mais je ne suis vraiment pas
certaine que ce soit en en rajoutant en
tout cas qu'on y trouve les solutions
certainement nous aurons et peut-être à
travailler avec d'ailleurs l'ensemble
des représentants des cultes à comment
peut être mieux armé je le disais les
enseignants mais pas forcément à
rajouter quelque chose qui coince crem
va pour un gamin de 13 ans ne veut rien
dire c'est quoi le fait religieux le
fait religieux
il ne s'inscrit forcément que dans un
vécu passé et dans la construction du
présent pour réussir pour réussir
ensemble demain voilà donc c'est gers et
matériels existent déjà
il faut par contre retravaillé peut-être
un peu plus le rôle des adultes dans
tout ça tu es un kuperman et je crois
pour terminer même je sache poignant
c'est juste une toute petite question
juste pour savoir ce que je veux savoir
si toutes les églises de votre
fédération sont en phase avec vous
est-ce que elles ont toutes la même
analyse de ce texte et en particulier
une question savoir si les églises
évangéliques ont la même position et ils
sont dans la même interrogation que vous
sur ce texte c'est faire n'importe quoi
même l'inventeur il pour terminer toute
la partie notamment sion s'est de fait
que on parle d'églises évangéliques qui
me fait penser à ça est ce que ça va
modifier les choses pour vous bien mais
c'est président oui d'abord je voulais
remercier l'intervention précédentes
assure voilà la difficulté rencontrée
dans l'éducation nationale sur ces
sujets qui sont très larges et
qu'évidemment un projet de loi comme
celui ci ne va pas régler mais voilà ce
cette insistance sur voilà le la
particularité au fond de ce métier
d'enseignement qui a des enjeux majeurs
voilà je la salue cette insistance et je
vous remercie de l'avoir d'avoir noté
aujourd'hui nous ne réglerons pas la
question évidemment ce matin pour ce qui
concerne la question des déserts la
fédération protestante de france
rassemble j'allais dire une brassée
d'église voyez je j'évoquais tout à
l'heure l'armée du salut les
pentecôtistes les adventistes les
bâtisses les évangéliques eux
voilà donc on est on est vraiment une
famille recomposée sans cesse en
recomposition
et donc les évangéliques qui font partie
de la fédération et même ceux qui n'en
font pas partie sont évidemment sont
évidemment sur ce plaidoyer commun nous
en avons parlé ça a été partagé ça a été
ça a été discuté donc ce texte a circulé
évidemment et il a été préparé de
concert par les représentants de la
fédération pour ce qui concerne les
dom-tom là je préfère laisser la parole
monsieur et pour ce qui concerne les
territoires d'outre-mer
il était tout à fait compréhensible que
l'on s'efforce à 2 essayer d'harmoniser
un peu disposition dans l'idée là encore
c'est pas l'idée qui pose problème
ce que nous constatons c'est que il ya
quand même deux départements en france
où nous rencontrons de réelles
difficultés
c'est la guyane et mayotte est
d'ailleurs j'avais déjà eu l'honneur
d'être entendu par la commission des
lois au moment de la
départementalisation de mayotte nous
rencontrent des difficultés parce que
dans ces deux départements
la loi de 1905 où le décret 2009 sens
peu importe ne s'applique pas et
s'applique ce qu'on appelle les conseils
d'administration ce 1939 il se trouve
que ces dispositions ne sont appliquées
qu culte qu'un seul culte de culte
catholique pour être bref et que depuis
plusieurs années les processions qui
habite sur place demande au préfet de
aussi reconnaître des conseils
ministration protestants et les dossiers
se perdent
jeudi se perde pas ce que c'est c'est la
seule réponse qu'on a le dossier c'est
perdure au fait ils leur font et ça se
repère de nouveaux dons en insistant
tout à l'heure sur les dos inutile parce
que on pourrait vous en donner de
nombreux exemples et nous ne comprenons
pas que cette question qui est une
question réel ne soit pas traité puisque
la loi
elle applique la loi de 1905 dans les
départements où il ya un décret
d'application de ladite loi mais qu'elle
ne règle pas du tout la question des
départements où n'existe pas donc si
yahia l'aïe
j'y prenais une expression qui devient
courante un trou dans la raquette qui
nous interroge pourquoi cette question
n'est pas traitée alors que c'est une
vraie question
merci je crois que nous arrivons au
terme de cette audition la commission
des lois monsieur le président monsieur
nous remercions et donc nous allons
continuer naturellement il n'est pas un
certain que nous n'ayons pas à revenir
vers vous pour des formes de cause de
questionnements ou de consultation
puisque nous avons quand même jusqu'au
mois de mars montre l'écart merci de
votre présence
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur madame reporter dame
sénatrice monsieur le sénateur permettez
moi donc de faire cette introduction que
j'ai déjà fait auprès de l'autre chambre
assemblée nationale s'agissant donc du
projet confortons les principes de la
république comme dans son exposé des
motifs le rapport de lois confortant le
respect des principes de la république
alors ce qu'il vise je cite en terminer
avec l'impuissance face à ceux qui
malmène la cohésion nationale et la
fraternité
face à ceux qui méconnaît la république
et bafoue les exigences minimales de vie
en société
conforter les principes républicains cet
objectif nous le partageons entièrement
l'exposé des motifs indique également
face à l'islamisme radical
face à tous les séparatismes face force
est de constater que notre arsenal
juridique est insuffisant il faut
regarder les choses en face
la république n'a pas suffisamment de
moyens d'agir contre ceux qui veulent la
déstabiliser
je cite donc leur l'exposé des motifs du
projet de loi
ce diagnostic repose certainement sur
des difficultés rencontrées par les
pouvoirs publics pour mettre hors d'état
de nuire des groupuscules qui profite le
certaines zones grises dans notre droit
et alimentent un climat de tension
recherché par les extrémistes de tous
bords
c'est ce climat de tension qui permet
aux extrémistes de se nourrir
mutuellement et de prospérer il faut
permettre à l'administration notamment
judiciaires d'exercer sa mission dans un
cadre clair et plus sûr il faudrait
aussi se donner les moyens suffisants
pour bien appliquer les lois existantes
et celles qui seront votés même si la
loi ne règle pas tout la loi pour avoir
un sens doit être effective
rien ne serait rien ne serait pire que
loi inappliquée une loi inappliquée
c'est une loi défier selon une
expression bien connue le combat contre
l'extrémisme se réclamant de l'islam est
aussi notre combat nous sommes
résolument déterminé à le mener avec
toutes nos forces nos cadres religieux
notamment les imams et aumôniers sont en
première ligne depuis bien longtemps
de nombreux jeunes ont pu être sauvée
des griffes de cet extrémisme grâce aux
efforts des imams de france
ces efforts doivent être soutenus et
renforcés idéologie extrémiste a fait le
terreau de principe aux drames qui ont
endeuillé notre communauté nationale
jusqu'aux années soixante dix le terme
d'islamisme était synonyme de islam
comme judaïsme et christianisme sont
synonymes et de la religion chrétienne
et de la religion juive
aujourd'hui en france islamisme est
synonyme d'une idéologie à combattre
dans le monde arabo musulman islamiste
mais souvent traduit par islam de
nombreux malentendus avec ce monde
peuvent naître aussi de ce décalage dont
le langage nous formons le voeu qu'ils
soient systématiquement suivis par les
adjectifs radical extrémismes aux
extrémistes islamisme radical islamiste
résiste
cette idéologie se nourrit d'autres
extrémismes qui gangrène les fondements
de notre société
faut-il le rappeler le tueur de
christchurch en nouvelle zélande qui
assassine et se contient fidèles de deux
mosquées néerlandaise avait déclaré être
inspiré par des promoteurs français de
la tuerie du vent au placement les
adeptes de cette théorie ont été
condamnés par la justice de notre pays à
maintes reprise pour provocation à la
haine raciale
ces condamnations ne les ont pas
empêchés de continuer à semer les
graines de la division entre les
musulmans et leurs concitoyens ce
séparatisme doit être également combattu
l'action envisagée par l'intérieur
messieurs gérald hernandes contre le
groupuscule les générations identitaire
fait partie de ce combat de nombreuses
dispositions du projet de loi sont
utiles et nécessaires pour mener cette
lutte contre l'extrémisme se réclamant
de l'islam
d'autres inquiètent les responsables de
culte parce que disproportionnée par
rapport au but recherché
ces inquiétudes ne les partageons
s'agissant des dispositions qui ne
devrait pas susciter de grands débats
mais les ajustements sent fortement
souhaitée il y a
les dispositions consacrées au principe
de neutralité dans les services publics
donc l'inscription dans la loi de la
jurisprudence sur la neutralité des
agents du service public et les
organismes privés en charge le service
public sans nouvelles extensions une
meilleure protection des agents du
service public une meilleure protection
des institutions et des services publics
face à des agents ayant fait la
démonstration de leur adhésion à des
idées ou à des actes de terrorisme
les dispositions destinées à protéger la
dignité des personnes et à garantir
l'égalité hommes-femmes en s'attaquant
notamment aux pratiques coutumières
coutumière dégradantes
les mariages forcés l'excision et
certificat de virginité pratique
prétendument musulmane et qui porte
atteinte à la dignité de la femme sont
prohibés dont le droit musulman car en
totale contradiction avec ses principes
et ses valeurs
les dispositions consacrées à la lutte
contre le disent les discours de haine
et les contenus illicites en ligne sont
essentiels nous savons aujourd'hui que
les et ne profitent de l'anonymat et de
la force de diffusion d'internet et des
réseaux sociaux pour déverser leurs
haines en toute impunité
les dispositions permettant de s'assurer
que tous les enfants de la république
bénéficie d'une éducation et d'une
scolarisation auxquels ils ont droit
sont nécessaires également pour lutter
contre des formes d'entreprises mortes
dont sont victimes les enfants de la
république lutter contre l' ingérence
étrangère participe à la sauvegarde de
notre souveraineté
des mesures sont proposées dans ce sens
certaines doivent être proportionnées à
ce but recherché je pense notamment
financement l'amélioration du droit
financier pour lutter contre le
financement du terrorisme sont aussi des
mesures essentielles introduction de
mesures de protection des associations
contre les entreprises mme
et les putschs dont elles peuvent être
victimes est importante pour nous les
avantages nouveau pour les associations
cultuelles ont été proposés je pense
notamment au bénéfice des immeubles de
rapport et les taux de défiscalisation
des dons
je reviendrai dans un instant sans avoir
de et exhaustive le temps ne le permet
pas le projet réaffirme
incontestablement des principes
républicains et introduit des outils
pour les conforter
avec un souci d'équilibré qui n'est pas
toujours facile à trouver
il est difficile aujourd'hui je pense
que le volet associatif est peut-être le
le volet qui inquiète le plus les
associations musulmanes
il est difficile aujourd'hui de de
prendre de savoir quel est le nombre
d'associations musulmanes qui sont sous
l'origine 1905 ou 1901 mais ce que je
peux dire de façon certaine c'est plus
de 90% de ces des associations
gestionnaires de mosquées sauce
l'origine 1901
en réalité selon les les associations
gestionnaires de mosquées
le cfcm conseil français de culte
musulman que je préside
on a bon son registre que les
associations qui ont participé aux
élections et qui ne représente pas à la
plupart des parts il représente à peu
près un millier d'associations parmi les
2500 aux 3000 à cette première
association qui gère les mosquées même
lorsque ces associations participent aux
élections
lord aussi sont déposés au conseil
régional du culte musulman et c'est eux
qui remonte ses dossiers au conseil
français de culte musulman et
l'information sur laquelle l'association
et de régis 1905 1901 n'apparaît pas
dans le dossier donc je serai peut-être
en chef incapable de vous dire qui est
le nombre exact de l'association de quoi
de gestionnaires de mosquées qui sont
sur le loi 1905 mais en tout cas ils
sont très minoritaires
auximines assurant qu'ils aient la
majorité et puis bien sûr les
associations de l'alsace moselle sont
sur le droit local
la réticence hulu ou le savez l'addition
de face à toute modification de loi 1905
n'est pas nouvelle même si les
aménagements de cette loi ont bien été
nombreux nombreux depuis sa promulgation
la construction la grande mosquée de
paris a été possible notamment grâce à
l'un de ces aménagements qui a permis
aux parlementaires de voter à cette
occasion une subvention de 500 mille
francs à l'époque à la mairie de paris
de faire donation du foncier
ces modifications n'ont pas remis en
cause les équilibres trouvés au début du
siècle passé de piloter le contexte a
changé
le gouvernement constate que l'arsenal
juridique dont il dispose est
insuffisante pour apporter les réponses
aux nouveaux défis
quoi donc de plus normal que de proposer
les ajustements nécessaires
c'est équilibre soit préservé les
structures associatives avec des moyens
réduits peine à mobiliser des acteurs
bénévoles pour assumer leurs missions
certaines compte certaines contraintes
introduites par le projet pourrait
aggraver cette précarité
ces contraintes accrues peuvent aussi
faire fuir les plus intègres et laisser
le champ brûlis le champ libre à des à
des aventuriers les extrémistes peuvent
choisir de ne pas utiliser les supports
associative les réseaux sociaux leur
offre déjà un espace très étendue et
moins contrôlés l'accentuation de
certains contraintes plus
particulièrement sur les associations
cultuelles ou à objets cultuels pourrait
être interprété comme une suspicion
généralisée à l'égard de ces
associations
or ces associations ne sont pas le
support habituel pour les activités de
ceux qui veulent déstabiliser la
république
l'immense majorité des associations
gestionnaires des mosquées sont sous le
régime 1900 à elle mène des activités
cultuelles culturel et social désormais
elles sont considérées comme association
à objets cultuels
ils seront soumises aux mêmes
contraintes que les associations sous le
régime 1905 sont bénéficier des mêmes
avantages
cela va engendrer des frais de
fonctionnement supplémentaires
importants la certification des comptes
serait une charge lourde notamment pour
les petites associations
l'objectif est sans doute d'amener les
gestionnaires de mosquées à se mettre
sous le régime 1905 à accéder et pandréa
qui criaient d'autres supports
associatif pour leurs autres activités à
titre personnel j'étais toujours
favorable d'abord pour inscrire le culte
musulman dont le paysage culturel
français
kim ajoutèrent majoritairement sous le
régime 1905 ou équivalent je pense
notamment diocésaine pour gagner en
rigueur de gestion nécessaires pour
obtenir la confiance des fidèles et des
donateurs et enfin pour avoir droit à
certains avantages dont bénéficient les
associations cultuelles
cette évolution souhaitée doit être
progressive les délais prévus pour la
mise en oeuvre du projet ne sont pas
suffisants
compte tenu de l'importance de la tâche
et il faut également un accompagnement
par les services de l'état et des
collectivités locales
la multiplication des contrôles
administratifs des associations objets
cultuels inquiète les associations
musulmanes
l'exposé des motifs du projet de loi
annonce clairement qui cible
essentiellement les associations
d'inspiration islamiste
cela pourrait présenter le risque de
jeter l'opprobre sur l'ensemble des
associations musulmanes
l'une des demandes du culte musulman et
d'autres cultes concerne les immeubles
de rapport
la réponse proposée à cette demande y
est à l'article 28 n'est malheureusement
pas suffisantes
en effet ce qui est proposé
et la possibilité pour les associations
cultuelles de procédés de posséder tout
immeuble acquis à titre gracieux les
anciennes générations des musulmans en
général des revenus modestes et ne pas
constituer un patrimoine immobilier a
légué aux associations nous demandons la
suppression de la condition acquis à
titre gracieux pour permettre aux
fidèles de doter leurs lieux de culte de
biens immobiliers vient suscription
collective la rente et une permettrait
d'assurer le fonctionnement des mosquées
est évidemment pas n'est pas question
pour nous de transformer des
associations gestionnaires nos mosquées
aux agences immobilières mais ça je
pense que ce celui trop cherche le but
recherché celui de satisfaire les
besoins d'une association gestionnaire
d'une mosquée peut être plafonnés pour
que le but recherché soir soit préservé
d'autres demandes que nous avons
formulées concernant les baux
emphytéotiques qui consiste à permettre
aux collectivités territoriales et les
associations cultuelles à conclure un
bail emphytéotique prévoyons au cours du
bail ou à l'issue de l'échéance une
option d'achat pour ces dernières afin
d'éviter que les communes on devient
propriétaire au terme du bail je pense
que le culte les cultures seront à
gagner pour la confiance que de d'avoir
donc à la possibilité d'acquérir le lieu
qui soit pas transformé notre
destination mais aussi pour le commune à
ne pas gérer ou à entretenir des
bâtiments nombreux bâtiments qui seront
donc à ceux sa propriété à l'échéance
des bas dès bons fit aux tic
la réforme de la caisse cavimac
permettre via une cotisation
complémentaire de bénéficier d un
d'imiter partielle d'une perte de
salaire ou en cas d'accident de travail
je sais que
le la cavimac a été formée surtout pour
les prêtres catholiques un certain
nombre d'imams sont sur la cavimac
aujourd'hui mais vous savez c'est les
imams c'est qu'il n'ya pas le célibat
dans quelles souffrances et des familles
qui sont derrière des enfants qui
doivent sur des études donc il ya des
frais que peut-être que que les prêtres
ne supporte pas dans leur vie de tous
les jours qu'il suffit qu'il y ait un un
an un malentendu avec le président
l'association l'immeuble se trouvant en
situation de cessation de travail et
dans ce cas les n'a pas de droit au rose
indignité partiel nous l'avons déjà vécu
pendant le coup vide puisque tous les
iem qui était seul à la cavimac ne
pouvait pas être en cessation partielle
de travail et donc l'association vous
devez dans tous les cas payer le salaire
de l'imam
tout en sachant que l'imam ne ferait
qu'une partie très infime de ses
fonctions au sein de la mosquée il
yad'autres d'autres d'autres moments que
nous avons de fait auprès de
gouvernements qui n'ont pas été prises
en compte mais jugée parce je passe à la
dernière mesure sur laquelle les le
culte musulman ne pourrait pas être
bénéficiaire à court terme je pense
plutôt à moyen et à long terme c'est la
défiscalisation passé de 66 % à 75 %
d'autres cultes vous l'exprimeront
également alors quoi dire de plus sur
sur le secteur
cette introduction préliminaire lorsque
la question des jeux des mesures qui
touchent à la police du culte ne sont
très en fait de nombreuses mesures sont
utiles et nécessaires notamment celles
qui permettent de d'empêcher les putschs
et de prise de contrôle par des groupes
puisque le des mosquées l'utiliser à des
fins qui ne sont pas les leurs la
question du ministre du culte
on sait très bien que dans le projet de
loi il est question du ministre du culte
notamment lorsque on introduit dans
l'association une assemblée libératrice
qui permettrait notamment peut-être de
désigner le 7 une intrusion dans
l'organisation du culte notamment parce
qu'il ya manque de définition du statut
mains du principe de deux coups de
ministres de culte
alors je vous dirai pas un mot sur le
sur le conseil national des imams et je
pense que s'agissant donc des ministres
de culte aujourd'hui nous le savons que
la définition actuelle ne permet pas de
devoir claire quant à au statut d'animal
il est important que les institutions
religieuses musulmanes elle-même
s'occupe de deux dans leur droit interne
de définir le statut réel de l'imam avec
les différents grades qui pourrait avoir
c'est normalement l'objectif de ce
conseil national dimanche sa création
toutefois la création du conseil
national isimat ne réglerez pas le
problème de ce problème d'un jeu dont
j'évoque aujourd'hui parce que le
conseil français du culte musulman
de par ses statuts n'a pas de dents
prise directe sur les associations
gestionnaires de mosquées et sur les
nichons de cuts tout ce qui pourrait
faire éventuellement ces deux données
désagréments mais ça serait volontaire
c'est à dire une sur deux que c'est lui
qui va faire la demande à au cfc faut
avoir cet agrément
voilà je vais m'arrêter ici peut-être
pour lui donner la possibilité aux
sénateurs et sénatrices de poser leurs
questions
merci monsieur le président madame v
rien merci monsieur président et merci
monsieur le président pour pour avoir
évoqué effectivement des différents
détails de ce texte
d'une façon plus générale je souhaitais
vous interroger pour savoir si
le vrai problème est d'ailleurs que du
coup on essaye de traiter dans la loi en
essayant de faire 1900 en 1905 n'est pas
le fait que la religion musulmane
à la différence d'autres mails très
étroitement le cultuel le culturel le
social comme vous le disiez voire même
le politique et c'est en cela que du
coup islamisme n'est pas forcément
négatifs sauf peut-être selon notre
regard ou la religion ne doit pas se
mêler de politique
d'où cette séparation qu'on essaye de
faire entre 1901 et 1905 et qui est
peut-être difficile à atteindre
justement par rapport par rapport au
culte musulman est là aussi des
questions ont été posées
une différence que nous fait entre le
culte et communautés et qui est
peut-être plus difficile à trancher
donc je voulais avoir votre point de vue
là-dessus et puisqu'on parle
d'association connaître votre point de
vue sur le fait que le régime de
dissolution administrative des
associations issues de la loi du 10
janvier 1936 et son évolution qui n'en
qui tend à conférer la suspension
d'activité par rapport au ministre de
l'intérieur on comprend bien l'objectif
qui est de pouvoir justement puisque
c'est essentiellement associatif ou
pouvoir lutter contre contre des dérives
potentielles
cette réunion ainsi que si un président
c'est aussi on a déjà échangé douze
chansons sur ces sujets parfois
compliqué alors merci pour voilà vous
propose que vous a expliqué je pense
qu'on a un objectif commun est que ce
texte a un objectif c'est de régler un
certain nombre de problèmes que la
france a devant elle que vous avez aussi
que vous avez aussi et que ensemble
devrait pouvoir y arriver alors vous
avez rappelé que l'état français
luttait contre 16 et ce qu'il veut nous
séparer vous
en tout cas nous mettre les uns en face
des autres
vous avez parlé de génération
identitaire mais vous avez oublié de
citer le ccf et barak
baraka city qui quand la méthode d
organisation complètement hostile à la
république il faut pas oublier ce que
prônait le ccf depuis quelques années ce
que prônait baraka city depuis quelques
années donc voilà je pense que quand on
parle d un il faut aussi parler des eaux
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
nous avons prend des ennemis communs
donc vous avez parlé aussi dans ce texte
de valeur que vous partagez dont on
parle aujourd'hui mais qui pour nous
sont une évidence ces terres que
l'égalité hommes-femmes est une évidence
la liberté d'expression est une évidence
vous avez parlé de ce deux sujets qui
nous touchent en tout cas moi en tant
que femmes qui tous me touche c'est les
mariages forcés l'excision les mariages
forcés très sincèrement vous le savez
autant que moi ce texte ne réglera pas
le problème des mariages forcés
absolument pas moi j'ai été maire
pendant trois mandats ça ne réglera pas
le problème religieux c'est parce que
c'est pas écrit sur le front de la jeune
mariée quand elle arrive à la mairie
mariage creusé en prévision donc c'est
plutôt quelque chose qui doit se
travailler au sein même des familles
c'est une éducation qui doit être portée
pour lutter contre les mariages forcés
retravaillé peut-être sur la place des
garçons aussi un voile à face aux filles
donc sincèrement c'est bien d'en parler
mais je suis très sceptique sur les
porter en tout cas sur les mariages
forcés
parce que malheureusement il y en a plus
qu'on ne le croit malheureusement ça ne
se voit pas quand on vient faire un
dossier donc ça je pense que vous devez
aussi prendre part en terme d'éducation
nous avait parlé aussi de la lutte conte
des discours de haine en particulier les
mosquées mais moi je me pose la question
quel rôle joue le rôle des imams dans
les mosquées pour lutter contre ce ses
discours de haine qui effectivement ne
favorise pas l'unité nationale donc je
pense que voilà il faut aussi qu'on
redéfinisse les obligations les droits
et devoirs de chacun en la matière vous
avez parlé de contrôle parce que
s'inquiétait mais ça ne peut inquiéter
que celles et ceux qui sont pas dans la
règle et dans la loi dire quand on est
contrôlé et qu'on ne supporte pas d'être
contrôlés c'est souvent
qu'on a des choses à reprocher donc
celles et ceux à mon avis mais
j'aimerais avoir votre avis là-dessus
celles et ceux qui n'ont rien à se
reprocher n'ont rien à craindre des
contrôles
clairement il me semble il me semble
après je voudrais juste vous poser une
question parce que c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas tous au fait des mêmes choses
je voudrais savoir exactement selon vous
combien de de musulmans sont vraiment
pratiquants parce que c'est toujours des
chiffres qu'on a qu'on n'a pas voilà
est-ce que vous avez une idée du nombre
de de réellement pratique en salle de la
communauté voilà parce que ça peut être
intéressant de le savoir est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir le nombre
de mosquées réellement connu enfin voilà
parce que c'est des chiffres qu'on n'a
pas bien et c'est important que nous
puissions les avoir voilà donc c'est des
choses très concrètes que je voulais
aborder avec vous et puis un dernier
point parce que je vais évidemment
laisser la parole aux autres je voulais
revenir deux secondes sur la charte des
principaux l'islam de france qui a été
signé récemment un peu dans la douleur
faut bien le reconnaître et je voudrais
savoir quelle est la qualité du monsieur
qui a signé au sein de la social de
l'organe musulmans de france parce que
c'est pas le président c'est pas le
responsable je vous connais je voudrais
connaître la qualité de celui qui a
signé au nom des musulmans de france
voilà j'en arrête là pour l'as merci
mesdames messieurs rail charte merci
président monsieur le président deux
questions la première concerne
la qualification des imams il n'y a rien
dans le texte qui nous est soumis à cet
égard moi je suis de ceux qui pensent
que c'est par là que cela devrait
commencer je rejoins un peu la question
posée par madame stage brigneau tout à
l'heure il est indispensable que comme
les autres religions à mon sens
les imams soient soient formés soit
qualifié j'ai bien noté tout à l'heure
que vous nous parliez du du conseil des
imams qui a été créée à l'initiative du
csm et vous disiez vous même qu' il
n'avait pas de puissance
il n'a y pas de contrainte ce texte vise
à vis de celles et ceux qui ne
voudraient pas aller dans ce sens et qui
plus est si je suis bien informé
il y aurait au moins deux composantes
du cfcm lorsqu'elles veulent bien y
siéger qui n'ont pas donné un accord à
l'égard de cette
proposition de deux labels de
labellisation par le cfcm ou par le
conseil des imams des imams qui
exercerait dans les mosquées
donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cela
est ce que le temps n'est pas venu de
discuter
d'une véritable exigence de
qualification pour les imams à cet égard
selon des modalités naturellement à
discuter puisque il nous sommes ici en
loi de 1905 qu'il faut naturellement
examiné de près deuxième question
l'exposé des motifs du projet de loi met
en avant le souci transparence pour
expliquer précisément les nouvelles
contraintes qui porterait sur les
associations pour avoir à l'époque fait
gt gt co rapporteur d'une mission
sénatoriale sur l'islam il y a trois ans
de tête
je m'étais rendu compte qu'il y avait
d'autres
deux domaines qui aurait mérité de la
transparence et dont il n'est pas non
plus dit quoi que ce soit dans ce texte
je vis tout particulièrement le halal
bien et nous avions à l'époque proposé
qu'il y ait une redevance à la halle
pour services rendus on en voit rien
dans ce texte
autre
phénomène qui mériteraient aussi une
plus grande transparence était le hajj
le pèlerinage
on en voit rien dire non plus alors à
quoi sert-il de mettre de la
transparence dans les associations alors
que par ailleurs il n'y en a pas autant
avoir une transparence totale si
effectivement on veut limiter les flux
d'argent frais pour le caser chien
organisé les attentats ou etc etc bref
est ce que monsieur le président s'était
donc ma deuxième question vous ne pensez
pas qu'il faudrait amender ce projet de
loi pour poser le problème dans sa
globalité donc en importance sur la
qualification des imams et en cohérence
sur les flux financiers je vous remercie
tibesar écharpe qui est effective encore
rapporteur de commission denquête en
2016 seul islam de france
madame benbassa merci pardon pardon et
la parole monsieur le président il ya
d'autres collègues qui veulent
intervenir manomètres bassa merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur
moussaoui
j'ai quelques questions assez simple on
a bien vu que
les composants turque du csm est très
liée à air douanes et
n'a pas adhéré à cette charte
donc vous connaissez les problèmes mais
on ne peut pas n'est ce pas délaisser
une des branches du csm il faudrait
trouver une solution et là j'ai vu aussi
que les autorités musulmanes de rhône
alpes
monsieur khattab et monsieur bah si qui
sont des personnalités bien connues des
musulmans de la région et n'adhère pas
non plus à cette charge sans compter la
réunion la réunion c'est une autre c'est
un autre problème on va pas rentrer dans
les détails parce que la loi de 1905 à
la réunion c'est pas du tout appliquée
de la même façon et la réunion à un
islam des usages de coutume
qui ne rentrent pas probablement dans
cette chape alors aiguë et si cette
chatte n'est pas signés alors elle seule
à quoi est-ce que vous avez la
possibilité d'agir de telle sorte que
cette charte soit signé par tout le
monde ou amender ce que demandent les
dignitaires et de rhône alpes
c'est plutôt d'être concerter davantage
et il reproche qu'on n'ait pas pris
aussi leur avis et c'est vrai que cette
charte est venu par le haut et pas par
le bas c'est ce que quand on lit
monsieur gaci et katell c'est ce qui
ressort peut-être qu'il y a une
concertation a à voir avec les
différentes mosquées les différents
dirigeants pour qu'il y ait pour qu'il y
ait une sorte d'entente afin de réformer
l'islam n'est pas le réformer parce que
vous avez signé richard il ya 6 millions
de musulmans en france ils vont pas dire
merci la charte et demain on change on
fait autre chose
moi je ne suis pas pour la réforme par
le haut elle ça n'a jamais servi dans
l'histoire ça a créé des problèmes pour
les religions il est la deuxième chose
si vous l'avez d'ailleurs évoqué comment
vous allez labelliser des imams
vous n'êtes pas des théologiens le cfcm
s'est des cadres je sais pas quelle
quelle est votre compétence pour
labelliser des imams
on sait que le judaïsme et l'islam ne
sont pas des religions et hiérarchisé
mais depuis le concordat il y à un
consistoire qui plus ou moins s'occupe
elle s'occupe de cette labellisation
parce que quand à la formation il ya des
problèmes l'école rabbinique ne marche
pas si bien que ça mais ai je fait un
vrai problème
est-ce que vous n'allez pas vous ne
pouvez pas à mon modeste avis vous
pouvait pas former des imams ou
labellisés des imams si vous ne faites
pas des lâches comité comportant les
différents grande mosquée va les
mosquées importantes de différents
mouvements et de l'islam avec des
théologiens des sociologues des civils
parce que là il emballe des imams comme
si c'était des enseignants non ce sont
des théologiens il faut dire à tout le
monde que c'est des théologiens la
théologie ne s'en prend pas à
l'université encore donc il faut trouver
des solutions pour labelliser ces imams
et sinon là aussi vous le savez mieux
que moi vous êtes un professionnel
elle va vous connaissez votre communauté
très bien j'utilise ce mot communauté
dans le sens très large de communauté
utilisez pas bhl les les dignitaires
protestants qui étaient là voilà ces
questions restent ouvertes et ce sont
c'est pas les associations qui pose
problème
ces questions là il me semble petite
entorse au principe que je vous ai donné
ta dah monsieur sueur merci cher
président je voulais d'abord redire les
questions que je ne poserai pas parce
que d'abord je entendu déjà beaucoup de
questions et puis je tiens à dire cette
conviction monsieur le président il
n'appartient pas à la halle et à la
république d'organiser les religions il
appartient à l'état républicain de
veiller à ce que les religions comme
toutes les entités dans ce pays respecte
la loi
si dans une mosquée ou dans un autre
lieu il y à des propos racistes et bien
de ses propos doivent être condamnés
sanctionnés en vertu des lois de la
république
ii ya ceux qui relèvent de la loi et à
mon avis c'est cela qui doit d'abord
essentiellement nous motive et nous
législateurs
voilà je tiens à faire cette mise au
point et j'avais une question
je crois que beaucoup des dérives qui
existe
certains en effet pourquoi l'euro
islamisme utilisation de l'islam contre
ce qu'il est contre son message contre
seuls les livres le livre banc des
livres mais dans ce cas là il ya un
problème qui est celui de
l'interprétation
il y a des d interprétation littérale
qui aboutissent à être totalement
incompatible avec justement le primate
la loi auquel nous parlementaires nous
devons veiller
donc la question de du respect de la loi
ce qui suppose finalement de mettre en
cause des interprétations fallacieuses
eux est une vraie question je voulais
vous demander comment vous réagissez par
rapport à ça monsieur le président merci
président monsieur csur monsieur le
président je vous laisse la parole et
puis ensuite après votre réponse nous
aurons madame gatel va là bas ça si
madame chagnon à lévis oui sur la
première question de porter sur la
dissolution administrative qui confère
évidemment ronis l'intérieur un peu plus
de pouvoir pour permettre de de
dissoudre une association us faire
cesser ces activités lorsqu'elles
présentent un danger pour la société
à titre personnel je suis pas contre à
condition qu'il y ait un débat
contradictoire et que toujours le
contrôle du juge soit possible et que
killip pas forcément d'arbitraire je
sais que les pouvoirs publics dans
toutes leurs actions n'a jamais été
arbitraire je pense que c'est plutôt le
contraire que vu souvent lent on
l'accuse de laxisme je pense que il ya
une nécessité dictée on peut être deux
de raccourcir les pets parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il ya des associations
qui profitent de délai octroyé par la
justice pour continuer à exercer
l'activité donc à titre personnel
fictivement dans certains cas lorsque la
situation exige les pouvoirs publics qui
doivent prendre les mesures nécessaires
pour faire cesser l'atteinte à l'ordre
public sur la question de ccf barak a
city je lisais pas citer parce qu'ils
ont télé sont déjà 10 août qu'on vous le
savez et lorsque j'ai parlé de jets de
deux générations identitaire je parle
surtout dont l'autre séparatisme qui
n'est pas prévue dans le projet de loi
la question de mariage forcé
effectivement ça c'est difficile parfois
de faire savoir que kadhafi peut être la
peur de thé représailles dont celle de
la famille mais je pense que la loi
permet quand même de d'ouvrir des
possibilités pour certaines pour celles
qui qui peuvent qu'ils font je dirais
confiance à la loi et à la protection de
la république je pense est important de
poser aussi certains limiter certains
règles et faire du travail pédagogique à
l'égard des femmes nadia des familles
sur la question du discours de haine
dans les mosquées
je ne partage pas votre avis sur le fait
que que ce discours de haine dont les
mosquées les triples est très fréquent
savez qu'il ya un million de personnes
un million de personnes qui se rendent
chaque vendredi dans les mosquées
si jamais si jamais il y avait que
quelques imams qui est qui qui prêchait
la haine dont les mosquées on aurait
peut être quelques milliers ou quelques
centaines de deux personnes qui serait
radicalisé
ce n'est pas le cas je pense à haut
rendement heureusement les imf en
travaux
justement je pense que les imams et si
nous aussi on n'avait pas des humains
qui jouer ce rôle-là de lutter contre la
haine aurait on aurait peut-être serait
votre façade et à des centaines voire
des milliers de jeunes radicaliser parce
qu'il ya cette ce travail là qui est
fait au niveau des mosquées ou judith je
répète une un million de personnes se
rendent à c'est pour répondre à une
question combien de personnes qui sont
pratiquants vous savez dans notre pays
on peut pas faire de deux sondages dans
ce sens là mais pas contre la plupart
des statistiques des fourchettes qui
sont donnés c'est entre 20 et 25% de
prat ici pan d'où la question d'un
million parce qu'on estime qu' à peu
près qui a entre 20 et 25% des personnes
qui se rendent à la mosquée le jour de
vendredi
mais je tiens à préciser effectivement
que les imans de jouer un rôle important
mais nous nous voulons aller plus loin
parce que souvent les jeunes ne se
radicalise pas ou à la mosquée parfois
aux alentours la mosquée parce qu'elle
est et des groupuscules qui profite de
la présence des jeunes aux alentours des
mosquées
mais c'est surtout au niveau des réseaux
sociaux et internet et c'est là où je
pense que les nos imams doivent être
préparées pour investir ce terrain ils
le sont moi et c'est qu'il faut le
reconnaître sur la question de coin est
posé sur sur musulmans de france luc
avait signé ces messieurs dames et
breizh qui était l'ancien président du
dodo et f il a été président et les
membres du bureau du ce 2 de musulmans
de france
c'est le représentant de musulmans de
france au sein du cfcm
puisqu'on vous savez millions de francs
s'ils ont un seul représentant au bureau
c'est monsieur times et presse
je joue sénateur richard effectivement
j'ai consulté votre projet de loi les
ports à votre proposition à l'époque de
ces de 2016 effectivement laquelle vous
vous souhaitiez que qui est quelque part
une définition de ce qui a la capacité
d'exercer dans et je pensais le projet
doit malheureusement n'a pas prospéré
mais je reviens sur le sur la difficulté
que rencontre le culte illusions et je
pense là à jouer être suffisamment clair
pour que vous ayez une idée sur sur la
difficulté profonde parce qu on pourrait
regarder de façon superficielle mais là
la difficulté majeure c'est le fait que
la création du conseil français du culte
musulman
en 2003 il a été construit sur la base
de trois documents indiquent comment ce
qu'on appelle l'accord cadre entre
fédérations de l'époque avait aussi un
document qui régit les rapports entre
l'islam et la république
et puis les statuts du cfcm le statut et
ses seins fait référence à ces deux
documents et je reviens donc sur la sur
le document accord-cadre qui stipule
clairement que le conseil français de
culte musulman est une structure légère
ce qu'on entende par une structure
légère
ça veut dire que elle n'a pas vocation à
remplacer les fédérations ou même à
parler en leur nom
en d'autres termes si je veut
schématiser un petit peu c'est un espace
de dialogue entre fédérations c'est un
guichet à travers les fédérations par
les pouvoirs publics
de fait le conseil français du culte
musulman nous dispose que d'un demi
secrétaire ne dispose pas de prêts de
budget de fonctionnement et il ne porte
aucune institution qui ferait
l'épaisseur de cette du conseil français
de culte musulman
le conseil national des imams lui même
il a été créé
adossé au cfcm est porté par les
fédérations c'est pas une institution
qui qui qui rentrent dont à l'intérieur
du cfcm en d'autres termes les décisions
qui seront prises au sein du ceni ne ne
relève pas de décision prise par le
conseil français de culte musulman dont
la construction de ces nids le cfcm n'a
été que coordinateur entre fédérations
si on ne comprend pas cette difficulté
car le conseil français de la
représentation du culte musulman ou
confondra pas l inefficacité de cette
institution
raison pour laquelle je plaide pour une
réforme profonde du conseil français de
culte musulman pour qu'ils puissent être
en mesure de mener à bien sa mission et
je propose que se compare deux
départements c'est-à-dire les murs qui
est représenté au niveau des
départements avec les départements
permettent de 2,2 d'élire leurs
représentants et qu'on reste plus dans
ce schéma de fédération qui dialoguent
entre elles et qui décide quand elles
veulent à l'unanimité au consensus mais
je pense la difficulté majeure c'est
celle là donc je pense que n'importe
quelle initiative prise par les
fédérations ne serait effective que dans
la mesure où le conseil français de
culte musulman est profondément réformé
pour lui permettre justement de chat
potté est de créer les institutions qui
sont nécessaires au culte musulman
aujourd'hui il est dans l'incapacité de
le faire parce qu'il fait pas partie de
ses prérogatives
je pensais je c'est important d'intégrer
dans votre analyse cette situation
raison pour laquelle effectivement que
les associations membres du cfcm et sont
complètement dépendants du secteur
c'est-à-dire le cfcm n'a aucune relation
de ré archers vis-à-vis des associations
n'importe quelle association à la donne
le droit de nommer son ministre du culte
directement son affaire sans faire appel
au conseil français du culte musulman ni
même à lui demander son avis les c'est
un contrat dire quand ces sept ans et
une situation contractuelle entre limal
et la mosquée effectivement si on change
pas cette situation là on va rester avec
les mêmes problèmes c'est à dire clé qui
immaculé pas c'est l'association qui
décide c'est l'association qui décide
que c'est cette personne là et les cafés
et les rapts à exercer les mamans je
pense que ça c'est l'idée de création du
conseil national des imams c'est
justement de dire que on devrait finir
avec cette avec cette logique il
faudrait qu'il ya un système régulateur
qui permet de dire que cette personne là
il a les compétences soient des diplômes
l'expérience etc et qui sont sanctionnés
par un agrément est celui qui n'a pas un
agrément
ne devrait pas normalement prêché et où
exercer le cul dans une mosquée on est
parent on n'est pas encore là même avec
la création de conseil national 10
images on est on sera pas encore là
parce qu'il faudrait réformer
en parallèle le conseil français du
culte musulman pour que cela puisse
arriver
et là effectivement ça ça pose la
question de l'intervention de l'état
mais je me suis donc dit en fait que les
nappes à l'état n'a pas à organiser les
cultes certes mais un moment donné je
pense qu'on devrait définir ce que c'est
on à la notion du ministre de tutelle et
dans nos textes de droit
et lorsqu'on n'est pas un appendice
finition suffisamment précises je sais
que c'est difficile de définir mais ce
n'est que d'une façon dont le cadre d'un
terreau religieux parce que c'est ça
chaque faculté la ccc prérogatives donc
on pourrait évidemment dire que
finalement chaque du doigt doit
s'organiser mais est ce que le contact
qui entourent envir le le contrat qui
existe entre le l'état et incultes ou sa
seule instance représentative est
suffisamment suffisant pour empêcher par
exemple que des associations musulmanes
indépendante qui sont même pas
l'intérieur du cfcm puissent être
sanctionnés ou lourd dire que l'on votre
imam n'est pas habilité je pense
qu'aujourd'hui même avec la création de
seignosse et on n'aura pas résolu cette
question là sur le sur la question des
redevances à l'aller pèlerinage
effectivement le projet de loi la loi
n'en parle pas parce que je pense le
souci législateur c'était de ne pas de
ne faire apparaître aucune spécificité
liée à un culte
on parle de cul d'une manière générale
et c'est peut-être là qui amène certains
certains collègues ou certains confrères
d'autres cultes de dire que finalement
les autres fuites sont les victimes
collatérales de combat contre les
l'islamisme radical je pense que il y
avait cette volonté de deux lits sature
de ne pas faire apparaître quelque chose
de spécifique au culte musulman parce
que la loi evin principes de droit
d'être de la loi exige donc lier une loi
qui est qui s'adresse à tous les cultes
mais vous avez raison que le travail
interne de 2,2 de plus musulman sa sauce
ce serait la solution
c'est pour cette raison que je dis en
fait que tout passe par une meilleure
une réforme profonde du conseil français
de culte musulman une prise en compte de
du terrain par en passant par le
département madame benbassa vous avez
dit que vous faites au sein du conseil
national il n'a pas détourné gyan en
fait la composition du cni il ya des
imams sédiments qui vont à gré les imams
ce n'est pas dessine pas les laïcs yvon
guay si la composition des saignées les
paritaire sens y avait des imams et des
responsables de mosquées
parce que nous avons tenu compte 2 de
l'espace dans lequel le cul de s'exercer
la mosquée de lorsqu'il ya un président
d'association et animales sont deux
personnes différentes centrales dans le
lieu de culte mais le dire le président
association c'est celui qui en contact
direct avec les institutions
représentatives du culte musulman
également avec les pouvoirs publics
depuis ce qui concerne le côté
administratif l'image il s'occupe de la
partie cultuelle nous avons souhaité
qu'il y ait au sein du ceni les deux les
deux présents d'une manière paritaire
mais pas contre l'agrément il est du
ressort exclusif des imams nous les
laïcs nous aurons aucun mot à dire sur
sur les sur l'évaluation des compétences
d'anima nous avons également demandé à
ce que les imams les candidats à
l'imamat puisse passer par des conseils
locaux des imams c'est donc ces dixièmes
qui vont d'abord un vie on veut dire
instruire le dossier de demande de
candidature de halima et une fois ceux
de ce dossier instruit au niveau local
la navy est envoyé au national et c'est
les mêmes au niveau nation qui vont
prendre souvent ils vont suivre la vie
locale
sauf sauf exception lorsque il ya des
éléments extérieurs qui permettent aux
imams au niveau national deux points de
notre décision sur la question de
je perds dans l'est j'essaye de les
prendre dans le sens de alors cela
chaque les principes sur la charte des
principes ou effectivement c'est un
document qui a été déjà prévu dans pas
mal de il y avait déjà un document 94 la
charte de l'islam de france à l'époque
où monsieur pasqua était mise intérieur
en 2000 il y avait les rapports qui
régissent les en fait le seul accord qui
régissent les rapports entre le culte
musulman et la république en 2000 et
puis il y avait en 2016 y avait aussi
une charte d imanche qui a été proposée
ou sur lesquels on avait travaillé puis
il n'a pas prospéré et celle ci dans
quelle est la vocation à être un peu
plus ambitieuse contre quant à
l'affirmation du principe de la
république que trois fédérations ne
l'est pas signé en réalité c'est pas sûr
vraiment sur les grands axes de la de la
charte qui est pas si nature puisque le
15 décembre je rappelle il y avait
unanimité des huit fédérations sur un
texte
le texte de 15 décembre si vous le
comparez aux textes de 16 janvier ne
diffère que sur les formulations et sur
des nuances sur les grands principes la
liberté la liberté de conscience et de
religion l'égalité hommes femmes la non
ingérence des états étrangers la non la
stigmatisation de l'islam
les cendres à des fins politiques tous
ces grands principes visitant il ya des
formulations sur lesquels en jeu je peux
les situer entre 5 et 10% de leurs
raisons qui me fait dire que dès le 17
janvier c'est à dire la veille même de
la signature que d'ailleurs les
fédérations les huit fédérations y
compris et 3 qui n'ont pas signé ont
signé un communiqué de presse dans
lequel ils disent que nous présentons ce
texte comme un texte consensuel
nous avons adopté les huit un texte
consensuel
après la question de signature c'est la
question des siens qui pose problème
les trois fédérations ne pense que
n'ayons pas été nous ne nions pas
un accord sur sur l'ensemble du texte
sans à 100 % sur les cinq dépôts sentent
ils voulaient pas apposé leur signature
sur les 5 10% sur l'accueil avait
divergences chose que évidemment que je
réfute dans la mesure où un texte fait à
une coproduction de 8 forcément c'est un
compromis et si ce compromis fait que
sur 90 à 95% il ya eu il ya unanimité
je trouve c'est un très bon compromis je
pense que tout le monde devrait le signe
et dont le cadre d'une dune d'un travail
collectif alors cependant sur les
divergences essentielles c'est sur
l'article 6 qui stipule en fait en lan
ont décrit ce que ce qu'on entende par
islam politique dans la version du 15 il
n'y avait pas des détails sur sur les
mouvements y avait pas de mouvements
frères musulmans tablir toi abhisit nick
setta il y avait aussi des tournures de
phrase dans laquelle on peut comprendre
que qu'il s'agit de la turquie divisés
lorsqu'on parle d'un régime hostile etc
c'était cette partie là pourrait
effectivement être source de difficultés
dans la mesure où il ya une une
formulation qui est trop explicites et
qui pourraient être d'ordre on va dire
conjoncturelle alors que la charte était
plutôt prévu pour des pour mettre les
principes et ne pas lier à des à une
actualité ou à une
d'ailleurs la liste des mouvements qui
pourraient être dont l'islam politique
n'est pas exhaustive raison pour
laquelle ils signataires disque pourquoi
en cible 3 par patou et et puis le fait
de d'une divergence sur sur même les
activités de ces federer de ces
associations visées par exemple tablir
frey pratique il concédé qu'ils sont
proches d'établir et donc le fait de
signer de les qualifier de l'islam
politique alors qu'eux mêmes ils se
disent que nous sommes
ils sont apolitiques pour eux c'était
signé quelques jours quelque chose qui
considèrent eux comme comme étant faux
mais juge insiste sur le fait que dès le
15 décembre y avait un accord sur un
texte ambitieux très ambitieux et qui
est qui diffère julien de 5 à 10% du
texte le 7 janvier et sur lequel tout le
monde était d'accord et le 17 janvier
y avait quand même un accord en disant
que les trois fédérations ont dit nous
sommes d'accord sur 90 à 95% du texte et
le portant avec vous mais par quoi
prenez pas on ne peut pas signer le
document parce qu'il 5 10% ce qui nous
pose problème
voilà je pense que j'ai fait le tour si
j'ai oublié quelque chose je le
rappelais joueurs voient leur dire
puisqu'un encore trois questions merci
je vais même gatel en suisse manama sa
cime et kate en visio librement ou si
vous permettez juste rajouter quelque
chose sur la question de la consultation
le effectivement dans ce qui est prévu
c'est que le séné fictivement été fait
de haut on m'a versé les fédérations
dire les fédérations sera ça représente
quand même quelques quelques centaines
de mosquées ne peut pas pourquoi ne pas
dire à apple un milieu de mosquées syrie
fédération ont consulté leur théologie
en corée pour écrire la charte
et puis il est prévu que une fois le
texte est validée par les huit
fédérations il descendra vers les
conseils régionaux du culte musulman
vers les imams les responsables de
mosquées et ses responsables pourraient
faire des amendements et donc le texte
n'est pas définitif dans la mesure il va
descendre vers les acteurs locaux en
fonction de leur retour de leurs
amendements le texte et pourrait évoluer
alors pour nous c'était la procédure la
plus simple si vous vous imaginez lancer
une consultation aura l'échelle de
national et de roque uhry de recueillir
quelques milliers de contributions de
faire la synthèse
si beaucoup plus difficile que de faire
un texte en précisant quelques éléments
importants qui nous paraissait en tout
cas pour les fédérations important et
puis de l'envoyer aux acteurs locaux qui
veut ils peuvent s'exprimer sur ce texte
en disant cette partie là elle elle
manque
il rajoute cette partie là il était il
est peut-être trop trop trop explicites
ont réduit est ce que je pense il ya ce
texte cela a le mérite de de proposer
aux acteurs locaux
quelques repères sur lesquels peuvent
s'exprimer autrement ce rare on mettra
peut-être quelques années à recueillir
les contributions et pour ne pas réussir
à faire une synthèse
notre objectif notre souhait est victime
oncle et l'interprétation des textes
rituel au niveau du système de france
soient harmonisées aux raisons de l'une
des missions du conseil national design
justement effectivement ceux de deux
tombés d'accord sur sur des
interprétations qui font l'unité de
l'islam de france
mais les interprétations toujours existé
présent pour la kia pige aux coûts
juridiques fusion qui existe de nos
jours et je pense que cette ambition de
l'islam de france 2 de travailler sur
l'interprétation qui correspond au
contexte français et le fait de de
construction des programmes de formation
des cadres religieux dans cet espace qui
le ceni nous permettra à terme d'aboutir
à une harmonisation des avis religieux
des différentes fédérations des
différentes imams et ça c'est un travail
de deux longueurs
à long terme je pense que je suis
confiant sur la mesure où les on dire
les visions notamment sur toutes les
partie cultuelle sont très proches et
pour de sa politique non nous on les
évacue complètement parce qu'on ne
souhaite pas que la politique que les la
religion soit instrumentalisée à des
fins politiques donc si on restera sur
la pâte
si on reste sur la partie rituels et
cultuel et à fortes chances que qu'on
arrive à des à des lectures complètement
harmonisée
[Musique]